hello freak [ __ ] he's very physically
it's a strange comparison to make but
back in the day used to hang out a lot
with Dennis Rodman when he was only for
the bowls and he had freakish strength
kind of similar body look very long yeah
like you wouldn't look at him and think
muscles right and Rodman could pick a
250-pound man up with one hand and lift
him over a rope I saw him do it at a
club he was acting up in Dennis de swert
rich over the guy picked him up like
this and then even people would remember
NBA fans a Dennis used to guard her
there Dennis used to guard shack one on
one yeah and that was when Shaq was what
you know three forty years I think
dennis was just and that was when they
had the whole thing you couldn't use
your hand yet at the elbow and all that
stuff he guard him one-on-one freakish
strength and you're like you look at him
you think how is that possible
yeah some guys just have that weird
mm-hmm whatever that is it's a lot of
times it's those long guys to something
is about long limbs and leverage and
it's like the ëthis if they have long as
they have a certain amount of muscle
with that long those long limbs and
longer average look at this look okay
freakish look and this you know this is
like the era I'm hanging out with Dennis
I mean look at Dennis's size compared to
Shaq he's crazy if you didn't know it
was Dennis Rodman it was just some you
know NBA scrub right you would think
there's no way that guy's gonna guard
him one-on-one
especially Shaq in his prime there
there's no way yeah it's rotten is a
crazy guy interesting speaking crazy
funny story please got a good story yeah
so used to hang out a lot with Dennis
and you know hadn't seen him for years
was at a restaurant in Chicago not too
long ago and and somebody said oh you
guys are friends with Dennis right yeah
yeah oh he's upstairs oh really we go
upstairs dennis is crying oh my god I
miss you guys me and my buddy we're
hanging out with them telling old
stories you know seven or eight years
haven't seen him this is great like when
you see a buddy you really love and it's
really affectionate and Dennis is one of
those people at some point he just gets
up any wanders away I think he's going
to take a piss
okay about 10 minutes goes by I say to
the waitress - Dennis leave yeah he left
okay I just figure he's gone it's just
the way he is right they wouldn't even
say goodbye just gone
I get up the next morning I turned the
television Dennis Rodman's in North
Korea okay I by the way I spent an hour
and a half with him he didn't say
anything about going to North Korea
right as I turn the television it's like
very controversial Dennis Rodman is in
North Korea so I text my buddy
and I say have you seen the news know
what I say turn on the television and he
said what channel I said it doesn't
matter and two minutes goes by holy [ __ ]
because he went through the same thing
you know Wow
yeah what is his deal with that North
Korean dude he just goes over there and
hangs out with him and yeah this is
really a genuine you know a naive
hearted person so in my best
understanding as he truly believes he
can affect the world in a positive way
so Dennis there's not a bad bone in
Dennis's body Wow Dennis has his issues
but he's not a bad hearted guy so in his
kind of crazy ideological frame he
actually thinks he's helping so he
thinks he can go over there and talk
some sense into that guy or by playing
basketball open you know whatever he's
yeah I mean so it's not a good that's
not a good shot I mean you know what I
mean it's this not a good look but yeah
I mean he's hanging around with a
murderous dictator hoping for the best
but that's what I mean about the naivete
and I don't mean to cast shade on Dennis
I really love Dennis it's been nothing
but a total sweetheart to my to me in my
life but I would in a very naive way
believe that he's actually helping it's
a very gangster move to go over there
though I mean it's just it's weird the
other side of Dennis it makes a certain
sense it's like I'll do it yeah remember
when he was dressing up and drag and
yeah
you know it's like I'll be that guy yeah
so it's somehow it sort of works in his
again I'm not trying to speak for him
but he was one of my favorite guys in
Celebrity Rehab because he was like
working out every day drinking water
yeah I used to go into Bulls locker room
after games and he would work out after
games really we go in to go because we
were gonna go out clubbing or whatever
and you go in the locker room and he'd
be working out we have to sit and wait
for him to
out for another 40 minutes after the
game and he played it wasn't like he was
had a knee injury I mean he played the
whole game like what kind of workouts he
like lifting weights or something
treadmill you know whatever whatever he
was doing why and he wasn't it wasn't
like light stretching it was like the
Energizer Bunny and then we go out and
stay out all night
Jesus state quick you want a quick story
so I'm hanging out with the Bulls it's
the first time they're playing Utah they
and it's a very it's if the series the
Bulls probably should have lost but they
didn't it's the famous game where the
famous series where Michael had the flu
and scored 36 points and if you know
that game it's like one of the most
famous games
Michael lidget had crazy flu and scored
36 and they won the game and they won
the series so in between one of those
games Dennis knows some billionaire
there's a day off we get on the
billionaires plane and we fly to Vegas
we stay out all night gambling and this
is Dennis like you know rubbing dice on
people's bodies and throwing the dice so
drunk they're balancing out of the you
know the craps pit and I mean just total
mess and you're thinking how is this
gonna help us win a championship very
much a fan mentality I'm thinking you
know naively I'm gonna kind of rein them
in so so we stay out all night we get up
then we would never go to bed we get we
fly on the private plane back to make
the morning press shoot around back in
Utah so we've only been we've only been
in Vegas for like eight hours so 9:00
a.m. I'm sitting in the stands I haven't
slept at all
they do the whatever the shoot around
and Dennis walks up and says let's go
back go back where the hotel no let's go
back to Vegas so after the morning shoot
around drove to the airport to fly
commercial because now the billionaire's
not swining back again and gets on a
plane commercial and has given me [ __ ]
cuz I don't want to go back to Vegas
with him Jesus crummy off day and this
is during the NBA NBA Finals so through
some sort of weird you know how the
world works I
up somewhere I don't play I go to play
miniature golf or something in this Park
City Utah where the Bulls were staying
and Phil Jackson and his families had
just happened to be there unlike an
off-day and Phil's given me the look of
death because I'm the one responsible
for Dennis going to Vegas the rock stars
you don't understand I'm the one who
tell him not to go I want to win a
championship or at least have one now
what are you gonna say to Phil Jackson
have you ever met Phil Jackson no Phil
Jackson is an intimidating guy he plays
very zen on TV but in person he's very
intimidating six seven six eight and he
was legitimately upset at you let's just
say it wasn't a nice encounter and I
love Phil Jackson I mean I loved those
years I loved those teams and I was
lucky to be around them a lot I used to
say look watching this teams like 1927
Yankees I mean you will look back very
fondly on this time and to even be in
that bubble at all and it was awesome
but yeah I mean catching shade from Phil
Jackson at the height of the Bulls thing
it was just so funny and I'm playing
miniature golf and you know this is so
uncomfortable
that is hilarious
[Applause]
[Music]